- This video is brought
to you by BetterHelp.
(upbeat lofi music)
What's up, guys?
Michael here to talk about the website
that has irreparably damaged
every nook and cranny
of my fragile brain, Twitter.
And while we're on the topic of things
that are objectively bad for
me that I can't look away from,
let's also talk about Elon Musk.
Because along with
solving the energy crisis,
building colonies on
Mars and naming a baby X,
he has decided to use some of his fortune
to purchase the aforementioned
hellsite www.Twitter.com.
Now it's not uncommon for rich people
to buy outrageous things.
So naturally, the internet
responded to this purchase
in a totally rational way.
Nah, just kidding,
everyone lost their minds.
And enough Twitter users
straight-up deleted their
accounts in protest,
such that some folks
were wondering if Elon
had already started to wield his powers
to drain their followers.
Others retreated to
Instagram, a part of Meta,
which is owned by this guy.
So, were people right to freak
out about Musk's Twitter bid?
Can he use the platform
for some type of evil?
Or is the internet always in
need of its main antagonist,
and Musk just happens to fit the bill?
And should we not be using
products owned by dudes
who might be bad?
Does any of this really matter?
Let's find out in this Wisecrack edition:
Will Elon Ruin Twitter?
And a quick note before we get into it,
buying one of the major tech platforms
isn't like buying a new couch.
Transactions on this scale
involve board members
and stocks and lawyers and
lots and lots of money,
which all take lots of time.
So at the time of this recording Elon Musk
does not officially own Twitter,
and the deal could still fall through.
And if it does, merely consider
this a thought experiment.
But before we dive in,
we wanna thank BetterHelp
who's sponsoring this video
in honor of mental health awareness month.
That's right, May is a month
dedicated to raising awareness,
providing support, and fighting the stigma
against mental health struggles.
This year's theme is
together for mental health
which encourages people
to share personal stories
and helps them making
everyone feel empowered
to prioritize their mental health.
So here, I'll go first,
I grew up in a family
that wasn't really open about
mental health and emotions,
so it wasn't until much later in life
that I was able to reach
out to a therapist.
And once I did, I realized
that I'd been depressed
for a lot of years,
but finally being in
therapy and opening up
and having someone tell me that
what I was feeling was okay
and that there was ways to approach this
was really a life changing situation.
So I, for one, wouldn't be where
I am today without therapy.
And I really encourage anyone
who's feeling that type of way
to seek it out for themselves.
Now, another goal of mental
health awareness month
is to improve access to
mental health services,
which has been one of
BetterHelp's goals from the start
regardless of your location.
This customized therapy platform
allows you to communicate
with your therapist through your choice
of video, phone, and/or
live chat sessions.
So if you're not in the mood
to be on video, no problem.
Plus, BetterHelp offers
unlimited messaging
so you can contact your therapist anytime
and as often as you like.
Because BetterHelp's network
has over 20,000 therapists
from a variety of backgrounds,
it's easy to find one whose expertise
suits your unique needs,
but it's easy and free
to change therapists
if you don't hit it off.
Once you sign up for BetterHelp
and fill out a detailed questionnaire,
you can start communicating
with your therapist within 48 hours.
It's not a crisis line
and it's not self-help.
It's professional therapy
done confidentially
and securely online.
Plus it's more affordable
than traditional in person therapy.
HSA benefits are accepted and
financial aid is available.
So if you're struggling
with your mental health,
try BetterHelp today,
or if someone you know is
really going through it,
try suggesting BetterHelp to them.
Visit betterhelp.com/wisecrack
to join the over 2 million
people already taking charge
of their mental health
with the help of an
experienced professional.
And when you go to
betterhelp.com/wisecrack,
you'll get 10% off your first month.
That's better H-E-L-P.com/wisecrack.
And now back to the show.
Now, before we figure out
if the Musk-buys-Twitter
outrage is warranted,
we need to take a brief
detour through the analog era.
Because while old-timey rich men
didn't know the difference
between a Dogecoin and a Bennifer,
they did know the power of
owning the means of cultural
and journalistic production.
For more on this, see the quaint
indie film, "Citizen Kane."
Dudes like William Randolph Hearst,
the inspiration for "Citizen Kane,"
used the newspapers they owned
to push their own agendas.
This allowed them to do things
like garner national support for a war,
Hearst was partial to the
Spanish-American variety,
or simply to seek revenge
against their industry rivals.
For the ultra-rich of
the early 20th century,
owning a newspaper was basically
like having a personal megaphone.
Eventually, feeling like their voices
still weren't quite loud enough,
the Hearsts of the world
began acquiring entire chains
of newspapers to further
propagate their beliefs.
But in the post-World War II era,
things like journalistic integrity
and editorial independence became trendy,
and the idea of a rich old dude
that lived in a castle
owning all the newspapers
started to seem a bit gauche.
And American journalism lived
happily ever after, right?
Right?
It did, it lived happily ever after?
Yeah, not really.
To say nothing about the
fleecing of American newsrooms,
pivots to video,
and the push from news to
content in the past decades,
we are once again living through an era
of super-rich people owning media outlets.
And also, an era of really good TV shows
about super-rich dudes
owning media outlets.
- Why shouldn't we do all the news?
Well, Kim Jong-Pop,
because that's not how
things work in this country.
- [Michael] Speaking of
television's favorite father figure,
the real-life inspiration for Logan Roy
is none other than Rupert Murdoch,
whose company News Corp
heads up hundreds of news
and media outlets around the world,
including your uncle Rod's
favorite channel, Fox News.
And, much like his on-screen counterpart,
Murdoch has been accused
of various misdeeds,
from hacking the phones of
journalists and celebrities
to straight-up using his media empire
to manipulate the national
political discourse.
And Murdoch isn't alone.
The ex-husband of noted
philanthropist MacKenzie Scott-
♪ CEO, entrepreneur ♪
♪ Born in 1964 ♪
- [Michael] Jeffrey Bezos,
threw down $250 million
to acquire the Washington Post in 2013.
Bezos' billionaire frenemy,
Salesforce CEO Marc Benioff,
snatched up ownership of
Time Magazine in 2018.
And The Emerson Collective,
an organization run by
widow of Steve Jobs,
Laurene Powell Jobs,
snagged a major stake in The Atlantic.
Meanwhile, The LA Times,
San Diego Union Tribune,
and a number of smaller community papers
were purchased by biotech billionaire
Patrick Soon-Shiong for $500 million.
- I don't believe you.
The liberal media would've
told me about this.
- There's no such thing.
The New York Times is
owned by NYT Incorporated
which is owned Altheon Ballistic Dynamics,
which is owned by the Murdoch family
who are owned by Halliburton.
(dramatic music)
- So, as you can see,
Musk's bid for Twitter
is far from the first time
that a rich one-percenter
purchased a media company,
maybe for the purpose of
directing media narratives
or making sure people can't
say mean things about them.
And to put my cards on the table,
the only truly mean thing I
have to say about Elon Musk
is that men who get hair
transplants are sellouts
and there is no room
for self-hating bald men in my circle.
Now, you might be thinking,
"Elon isn't like the
other billionaire boys,
because he's not buying a
newspaper or cable news network
to reinforce his own ideological agenda,
he's just purchasing a
demented global town hall,
where he will sit back
and let everyone express
whatever views they want,
280 characters at a time."
And while we get where you're
coming from, in another sense,
the fact that Musk isn't
simply buying a paper
or media network makes
things even more extreme.
That's because he's not
just buying a media source,
he's buying the place where
a majority of news media
and information is posted and distributed.
In other words, he might
not be buying a newspaper,
but he's purchasing the
proverbial digital printing press
and distribution networks used
by every news and media company,
along with basically every
writer and journalist,
on the planet.
And in doing so,
he's going beyond the trend
of members of the ruling class
owning media companies as pet projects.
And to understand what this means,
we need to talk about something
called platform capitalism.
To understand what it is,
let's start with the
first part, platforms.
While they are sometimes
places you can stand
while you wait to catch a train
to a magical school of wizardry,
these days platforms usually
refers to apps and websites
like Uber, AirBnb, and Facebook.
As the book, "Platform
Revolution" puts it,
"A platform is a business based
on enabling value-creating interactions
between external producers and consumers,"
providing "an open,
participative infrastructure
for these interactions"
and setting "governance
conditions for them."
Or, as theorist and academic
Nick Srnicek puts it,
"What are platforms?
At the most general level,
platforms are digital infrastructures
that enable two or more
groups to interact.
They therefore position
themselves as intermediaries
that bring together different users:
customers, advertisers, service providers,
producers, suppliers, and
even physical objects."
And unlike, say, a newspaper,
which is a physical product
that can be sold for profit,
platforms don't really
create anything of value,
at least not in the traditional sense.
According to Srnicek, "By
providing a digital space
for others to interact in,
platforms position themselves
so as to extract data
from natural processes,
weather conditions,
crop cycles, et cetera,
from production processes,
assembly lines, continuous
flow manufacturing, et cetera,
and from other businesses and users,
web tracking, usage data, et cetera.
They are an extractive
apparatus for data."
So while old-school billionaires
might've used their media companies
to push their own views and
agendas onto media consumers,
new-school billionaires like
Musk use platforms like Twitter
to extract data from those of
us who use these platforms.
In this way, we can see
Musk's acquisition of Twitter
as evidence of what writer
and professor Jill Lapore
refers to as Muskism,
or, extreme capitalism.
As Lepore sees it, a childhood of reading,
and, according to a recent
video on this channel,
misreading science fiction
has led Musk to favor a sort of capitalism
which is more theoretical than industrial.
As she describes it,
"I think it is an extreme
form of capitalism
in the sense that it's plutocratic.
It's something old again.
There's a lot of feudalism in Muskism.
It's like there are these lords
and the rest of us are the peasantry
and our fates are in their
hands because they know best."
And the idea that Musk's
brand of capitalism
is sending us back towards
Feudalism caught on quickly
after he announced his
purchase of Twitter,
with people expressing concern
that, with Musk in charge,
every time we tweet we'll
actually be doing free labor
on Musk's digital land.
But Srnicek questions
the argument that posting
is equivalent to doing unpaid labor.
He says that, "Free
labor is only a portion
of the multitude of data sources
that a company like Google relies upon:
economic transactions,
information collected by sensors
in the internet of things,
corporate and government data,
such as credit records
and financial records,
and public and private surveillance,
such as the cars used to
build up Google Maps."
So even when we're not actively posting,
if that's something you're capable of,
we're still creating
data simply by existing,
or being alive in, our
largely digital economy.
We're creating data
basically all the time.
Srnicek goes on to
further disconnect posting
from traditional labor,
"Beyond the intuitive hesitation
to think that messaging friends is labor,
any idea of socially necessary labor time,
the implicit standard against
which production processes
are set, is lacking.
This means there are no
competitive pressures
for getting users to do more,
even if there are pressures to
get them to do more online."
While a feudal laborer
couldn't really choose
to not work their land,
we can choose to put our
phones away and not post.
So the good news seems to be
that when you tweet at
your favorite director
giving them your notes
on their latest release,
you're not technically
doing free labor for Musk.
The bad news is that no one is forcing you
to tweet other than yourself.
But labor or not, he's collecting
a fuck-ton of your data.
Like, you know, that
you're watching this video.
Right now. In your house.
But let's get back to
the negative reactions
to Musk's Twitter acquisition.
Much of the anger seemed
to be based on the idea
that people enjoy using Twitter,
but they don't enjoy
the person of Elon Musk,
and thus, Musk's acquisition of Twitter
means they will now enjoy it less.
Sort of like if some dude who
bullied you in high school
bought your favorite sandwich shop,
and now every time you bite
into that turkey pesto sub,
you can almost taste the toilet water
he used to dunk your head in.
For others, it seems
that they worry that Musk
will somehow impose his
personal political views,
whatever they are, onto
the platform in some way.
And this isn't an unfounded worry,
as according to Srnicek,
"Platforms are also designed
in a way that makes them
attractive to its varied users.
While often presenting
themselves as empty spaces
for others to interact on,
they in fact embody a politics.
The rules of product
and service development,
as well as marketplace interactions,
are set by the platform owner."
Though, as of the writing of this script,
the main changes he's discussed
are charging brands and larger
accounts for quote tweets,
potentially monetizing viral tweets,
as well as the addition of an edit button.
But for many it simply seems
to be the case that Elon Musk
owning a popular platform
is crossing some type of moral boundary.
But that worry also seems
to imply that up until now,
Twitter was owned by the good guys.
And who are those good guys?
Well until Musk takes over,
the majority shareholders of Twitter
are Morgan Stanley Investment Management,
The Black Rock group, Vanguard Funds,
and some Saudi investors.
None of these dudes have ever been accused
of being too woke.
And Black Rock was at one point
the world's largest investor
in coal plant developers,
and is currently one of the
world's largest investors
in weapons manufacturing.
I mean, say what you will about Elon,
but at least the dude is more
into batteries than coal.
And rockets that go into
space more than rockets
that accidentally hit
hospitals full of civilians.
So what makes Elon Musk any better
or worse than those companies?
Or, for that matter, the
owners of Meta, Google, Amazon,
or any number of prominent
digital platforms?
Some of the outcry seems to
come from a genuine desire
for a version of what we
could call ethical capitalism,
or ethical consumerism,
where our money, and,
in the case of Twitter,
our time and attention,
is spent supporting brands and companies
that share our values.
This mentality has been on
the rise in recent years,
and is particularly prominent
amongst millennials.
There are even financial funds
that specialize in
investing money in companies
deemed to be adequately ethical
and/or environmentally friendly.
This attitude looks like someone
who won't eat at Chick Fil A
because their owners have a history
of funding anti-LGBTQ organizations,
but who will eat at Chipotle
because of their commitment
to sourcing sustainable
and organic ingredients.
But just like you can't
bang your way to virginity,
some would argue that you
can't capitalism your way
to an ethical society.
It seems like the phrase,
"There is no ethical
consumption under capitalism"
is becoming a crucial
proverb for our times.
The idea here is that if we apply
the standards of individual ethics
and morality to capitalism,
which functions according to economic,
and not moral logic, we'll
be consistently let down.
Much like the recent controversy
around Joe Rogan's deal with Spotify,
which similarly led users to proclaim
that they were leaving
for other digital streaming platforms,
we see these contradictions
when people want brands
to share their ethics and politics.
And it's not hard to see
the contradictions at play
when companies attempt to
convince consumers that they are,
in fact, doing ethical stuff.
For example, recently Blue Bottle Coffee
started piloting a shift to make oat milk
their default milk,
for the purposes of reducing
greenhouse gas emissions
that come from dairy production.
Which seems great.
Until you realize that
Blue Bottle is owned
by the Nestle corporation,
who, along with being a
generally very, very bad company,
they literally did child slavery,
also has a full-on dairy division.
So even if you feel good
about your oat milk latte,
you're also giving money to
a company that was sued for,
and I can't repeat this
enough, doing child slavery.
- It's not handmade in USA,
it's pronounced "hahnd-made in Oosa."
The Hand people are a
Vietnamese slave tribe,
and USA is their island prison.
They made your jeans.
Do you know how they get
the stitching so small?
Orphans.
- On the other hand, there
are those who might say
it's unethical to eat
things like fast food,
due to things like food quality,
environmental impact,
and labor conditions.
And that it's bad to eat factory farmed
and non-organic meat and produce,
again, for environmental
impact and working conditions.
But what does that mean for
people who can't afford organic,
grass-fed chicken breasts
or gluten-free cashew mac and cheese?
Are they to be held morally responsible
for their consumer choices?
Or, are they simply doing
whatever they need to do
to survive in a system
that isn't providing a
lot of other options?
If you can afford to patronize companies
that treat the planet and
workers well, that's great.
But if you can't, you shouldn't
be held morally responsible
for systemic issues that
you have no control over.
Which brings us back to the question
of whether or not Elon Musk
is going to ruin Twitter,
and if leaving the platform
is a useful response
for folks who don't dig
Elon's whole libertarian space pirate
who is also an online
psychopharmacologist vibe.
So, if people decide to leave
Twitter, where will they go?
If you're able to simply abstract yourself
from social media altogether,
we have nothing but the deepest
love and respect for you.
But for those who are dependent,
either socially or professionally,
on social media platforms,
where might you go if the worst guest host
in the history of SNL
succeeds in buying Twitter?
Maybe you head over to
Instagram or Facebook?
Well, they're both owned by Meta
which is the brainchild of this guy,
and if you find him to be
a significantly better person
than Musk, there you go.
But maybe you're not
into Zuck's misinformation-happy
platform either,
so you're gonna park your
digital self firmly on TikTok?
Oops, they're owned by
Chinese company ByteDance,
which has been accused of censoring
and surveilling content on
behalf of the Chinese government,
which is not the best.
So maybe you go with a
platform not connected
to global corporations
and find some new friends on
Craigslist missed connections.
What are you trying to
do, get yourself killed?!
The point is, it's pretty hard
to fully disconnect ourselves
from companies that
vary from kinda sketchy
to literally doing human rights abuses,
because platforms of all
types have become inextricable
from modern life.
So unless you want to
go fully off the grid,
you're going to have to navigate
some type of relationship to platforms
owned by people with
names like Mark, Jeffrey,
and yes, even Elon.
And we're not saying it's good
that Musk is buying Twitter,
but we are saying that moral categories
like good and bad
aren't the most useful
metrics to apply to platforms
whose sole purpose is
the extraction of data
for the sake of profit.
Asking a platform to be moral
is like asking a couch
cushion to be delicious.
Musk's reign as CEO of
Twitter might be bad,
it might be good, it will
almost definitely be weird.
But one thing we do know for sure
is that he isn't the
only super-rich person
who sees value in owning a platform
whose sole purpose is the
collection of monetizable data.
And as more of our social
and professional lives
get inextricably linked
with these platforms,
we're all kind of stuck here,
whether or not we continue
sharing our flaming hot takes
on Twitter every time we
drink too much caffeine.
But what do you all think?
Is Elon going to destroy the
peaceful Twitter community
we've come to know and love?
Or is the reaction to
his recent bid overblown?
Let us know in the comments.
Hit that subscribe button
like you're launching
your high school bully
into deep space on a SpaceX rocket,
and don't forget to ring that bell.
Thanks to our patrons
for all your support,
and be sure to check out
our new Patreon perks.
And, as always, thanks for watching.
Later.
(upbeat music)